so who else is propagandizing you and
can't pull their heads out of their
butts I was 50 50 on showing you this
clip that we're about to show you
because as I mentioned earlier in 2015
when when the Reuben report officially
took off when I started doing a long
form interview show show uh show so we
had left The Young Turks already where I
was doing more of like a view Hot Topics
kind of thing and we started doing the
long form interview my first sit down it
was it was basically eight years ago
this week if I'm not mistaken it was
SEPTA I think we did it on September 9th
today September 5th we did it on
September 9th uh 2015.
it was with Sam Harris a neuroscientist
and mindful meditation expert I guess
you could say Sam Harris said he had
been an outspoken critic of religion he
was part of the new atheists all this
and he was getting involved in politics
he was also very critical of
collectivism and a lot of the stuff that
was wrong with the left and
okay that was the first interview that I
did over the last couple years Sam has
sort of you know we've watched the new
atheist movement fall apart Sam really
kind of went crazy with Trump
derangement syndrome this segment you
know you know what I'm gonna actually
make an official state this is the last
time we're going to talk about him on
the show because this actually brings me
no pleasure because Sam and I became
friends he and his wife came over to
dinner at our house many many times we
went out a lot and watching him kind of
go off the deep end so this is the last
time we're going to talk about him on
the show uh but Sam Harris uh who was in
who is the reason I'm playing this is
because he was one of the thought
leaders of what was thought to be the
same left uh he went on Russell Brand's
podcast and Russell Brand I would
include in an actual saying left he may
be the only guy left half of Bill Maher
but Russell Brand has podcasts on Rumble
Sam went on there and they talked about
big Pharma and and listened to Sam after
all of this coveted craziness all of the
lies all of the money that they made and
the immunity that they got from lawsuits
and everything else Sam's still
defending big Pharma there's some
trade-off between
uh
remunerating people for the risks they
take and and the and the and the and the
work they do and allowing despite the
despite the obvious possibility of weird
incentives allowing for people to get
spectacularly wealthy when they get
lucky based on their own intelligence
right they they they produce something
that's immensely valuable to us a new
antibiotic and we should let them get
rich right and if you have an
alternative to that well by by all means
uh express it but to my knowledge we
haven't found one I would like to
express an alternative but also outline
a few things within your hypothesis no
one is conducting that research at
Pfizer precisely because it isn't
profitable so this tells us precisely
the mentality that governs at Pfizer and
when indeed there is innovation you
might find that it came from bioentec in
Germany who are funded by the German
taxpayers and you might find that
Pfizer's profits were garnered by
charging the American taxpayers who paid
for that Pfizer
apparent Pfizer Innovation but actually
a bioentec Innovation anyway look I
really want to give the devil his due on
this one I am all for people getting
rich I love capitalism and if you bring
something to the market you create an
incredible new vaccine that actually
works you create an incredible new glass
that holds water in it so people
foreign
that guy deserves some cash I am all for
that the problem is as Russell is
alluding to the entire system is rigged
you don't want to create a system where
big Pharma is completely unable to be
sued if they kill a whole bunch of
people or where they can hide all of
their records or the same people who are
supposed to be watching what big farm is
doing all end up in the government or it
turns out that the people like Anthony
fauci who are supposed to protect us
from viruses are also funding things
like gain of function research in Wuhan
Labs
etc
foreign